Speaker 1: Lying. Republican Congressman George
Santos would use a fake Jewish sounding name to
raise money from Jews. Folks. I can't. I can't.
It's. There is no depth to low for this guy. This
is just unbelievable. CNN's Anderson Cooper
interviewed Gregory Maury Parker. This is a
former friend and roommate of Jorge Santos
and in speaking to Anderson Cooper. Maury.
But Maury Parker explains that
when Jorge Santos would run,
Go Fund Me is which is another scam which we will
get to. If he needed to entice Jewish donors,
he would use a Jewish last name. Listen to this.
Speaker 2: How long did you actually live
together? We were only roommates for a few
months. And I also knew him as Anthony Zebrowski.
So you knew he was hit? Why did
he say he had two names then?
Well, he. He used the Borowski for
his friends of Pax United. Has his
go fund me. And he would say, Oh, well, you know,
the Jews will give more if you're a Jew. And so
that's the name he used for his GoFundMe needs.
Speaker 1: And what was he having a go.
Speaker 2: Fund me for back then? Hmm. He had
a charity Friends United. I was supposedly to
help out with, you know, sick animals
and things like that. There's actually
just an article released from one of my
reporters has been interviewing me a lot.
Track one, Speak about how he conned a homeless
military bat out of $3,000 for his service dog.
Speaker 1: Okay. We're going to get back to that
second part. But using the last name Zebrowski
Zebrowski Zebrowski. I don't know which version
in order to entice Jewish donors to donate. Now,
there is a ton of Jewish related stuff going on
with Jorge Santos, where he claimed to be Jewish
in terms of his family history. Another example is
he got into a discussion on a podcast called Loud
Majority about whether Jewish people learn Spanish
or not. Take a listen to this. I actually think.
Speaker 2: We should do the whole the rest
of this in Spanish. I think so. Let's see
how your public education took a once private
school, right? I didn't you know, I didn't. You
know, I college. There you go. But you know, what
I did was I was supposed to learn Spanish. Jewish
people don't learn Spanish. You know they don't
because that's how they become more culture by
learning Spanish. Yeah, that's how I learned.
Speaker 1: And now this is when he was still
lying about being Jewish. You'll notice it's
lies on top of lies. On top of lies. Now,
beyond parody. This guy, the George Santos that we
now know, lied about everything. And soon you will
see bilked a disabled veteran out of money for his
dog. And the dog died. Okay. He has been assigned
to the House Small Business Committee and the
Science, Space and Technology Committee. Here is a
report from yesterday from MSNBC. Jorge Santos is
going to serve on two committees in the House of.
Speaker 2: Representatives on behalf.
Speaker 1: Of the Republican Conference. They
will be the Small Business Committee and the Space
Science and Technology committees. And I actually
just caught up with the House speaker, Kevin
McCarthy, a few minutes ago as he was leaving the
Capitol. He confirmed to me our reports about.
Speaker 2: The Santos committee
assignments. And yeah.
Speaker 1: So he's going to be
on committees. This guy who has lied about
everything, scammed people, stolen money,
lied about inventing carbon capture technology,
lied about being Jewish, lied everything.
He gets committee assignments. And one other
funny note from this interview with Santos,
his former roommate with Anderson Cooper, I guess
that Santos stole a scarf from his friend and then
wore it to the Stop the Steal rally or whatever.
Speaker 2: And I understand he was actually
wearing something he took from
you at a pre January six rally in
Washington. If is asked to believe that he has
the audacity. Yes. Wait a minute. That is, he's
wearing the scarf, stolen scarf to a store,
steal the election rally. You have to love
the irony and the audacity, quite frankly.
Speaker 1: So a complete and total liar.
And this isn't even the half of
it. Listen to this next story.